We called this the Stentrode.
For peoplewith paralysis,
this is a return to life.
Graham Felstead, an incredible
human being sufferingwith ALS,
became the first person
in the world to receive
and use one of these
brain-computerinterfaces.
Once it's in place, it's connected
to this tiny antenna
that sits under the
skin in thechest.
This collects the raw brain data
and sends it out of the body
wirelessly to then connect
withexternal devices.
It's kind of like learning
how to ride a bike.
It takes a bit of practice,
but onceyou're rolling,
it becomes natural.
Now I just look on the
screen where I want to click
and I'mtexting, messaging
the world via Twitter.
Graham, he said, as his
ALS was progressing,
that itgave him immense
comfort to know that
even if his body was failing,
he was always going tobe able
to tell his wife that he loved her.